I mean it's just an epic comeback I
absolutely agree with that yeah
that's now if Magnus wants to play it
safe he'll just take White's Pawn even
at the cost of the black Bishop because
that end game is a draw okay we do go
into that he could also have moved his
Bishop but uh this one
we'll get to learn some end game
technique some endgame strategy
from both of them I mean this one is
quite a simple draw I would say
compared to rook and Bishop versus what
I saw the other day yeah that one yeah
you know you have to know the defensive
resources here is just the case of just
chucking the white king I mean how how
long will they play this out I think
we'll see our guys who try for at least
20 moves or so maybe not the full 50.
yeah as you say Ivanka the whole
strategy for black at some point you
will get your king pushed to one of the
edges of the board but you just check
from afar and then pin the White Knight
that's all you need to know and just
don't let the king sit opposite opposite
each other if your king is trapped on
the back rank